you know
um and I just thought it was so
interesting because I said your
definition of marriage is letting
another dude bang your wife on camera
people like you are ruining the sanctity
of marriage it's an insult to people
that take marriage theories and I really
I really believe this I really believe
that true marriage is between two
virgins I believe some non-virgins get
lucky and you know they're in a society
where that stuff's accepted but I really
think it's true marriage but now now
we're getting to the point we're
literal and I'm not even you know I know
sometimes I'll be like guys two bodies
poor it's more for definition purposes
but you know now now we're getting to
the point where literal prostitutes
are are getting rings